salut qu'est-ce que tu fais là je
te le rends je ne veux plus de lui mais
il est abîmé il n'a pas d'autre endroit où aller
il habite chez moi depuis deux
ans Oh papa je suis vraiment désolé mais tu sais celui de
Tony  vivre dans le sous-sol
ton ex-mari ne devrait pas vivre dans
ton sous-sol ce n'est pas la bonne façon
d'être divorcé d'accord je ne sais pas où
je vais te mettre papa n'y va pas
maman est là-dedans tu peux avoir  le ramène
Terry je ne veux plus de lui c'est
tellement mieux d'être avec Sharon d'accord
je ne réponds pas que nous sommes allés au
Metropolitan Museum of Art qu'est-ce que tu as
aimé en musique qu'est-ce que j'ai aimé je vais
te dire quoi  J'ai aimé j'ai aimé les
statues romaines antiques j'aime l'
amor médiéval j'ai aimé les
bijoux étrusques tu vois j'aime aller au
château pour avoir un expresso un bon
pinot c'est ce que j'ai eu un panini dans un
cercueil Rudy un cercueil ennuyeux poussiéreux pourquoi
Jess ouais  eh bien, vous êtes fou, c'est
comme avoir une conversation avec un
instructeur Jack quoi d'autre était si génial
Capitaine Jack oui ton Capitaine Jack le
Jack volant tu sais ce que tu es tu es
comme une fuite de gaz on ne te sent pas on
ne te voit pas mais tu nous dis tous en
silence dis moi ce que tu as fait d'autre avec
Sharon Creature  du lagon noir